foreign
[Music]
to enable them fall up their DNA as the
parents come to claim their students who
have been here
[Music]
the Allied Democratic forces is
originally a Ugandan group that was
formed in the early 90s in order to
oppose the Ugandan government and this
group was then later pushed to the
eastern part of Congo where they have
been wrecking Havoc for the past two and
a half decades the Ugandan government
with their Congolese Partners have
established what they call operation
suja which is a joint military operation
against the ADF and when they are under
this kind of pressure they then start
attacking civilians
[Music]